Oh
Bonz provide support for the body and
aid in its movement the place where two
or more bones meet is called a joint
joints may be immovable slightly movable
or freely moveable
a synovial membrane surrounds movable
joints inside the membrane synovial
fluid lubricates and nourishes joint
tissue such as cartilage articular
cartilage is a tough slippery covering
on the ends of the bones which allows
smooth joint movement
joints give the body flexibility
precision of movement and help in
supporting the body's weight
arthritis is any disorder that affects
joints it can cause pain and
inflammation osteoarthritis or
degenerative joint disease is the most
common type of arthritis it's usually
seen in older people the joints most
commonly affected are in the hands knees
hips and spine
often the cause of osteoarthritis is
unknown but it may be due to a
combination of the following risk
factors a family tendency for this
condition
being overweight
a joint injury such as a fracture
repetitive strain from activities such
as sports
and problems with the bones in a joint
not lining up properly over many years
these factors can wear away the
articular cartilage the exposed bony
surfaces rub together
this along with the growth of bony
projections called bone spurs
swelling pain and limited movement of
the joints
there is no cure for osteoarthritis but
a combination of treatment options
control the symptoms for example
medications can reduce joint
inflammation and pain common medications
include acetaminophen
and non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs or NSAIDs
an ice pack may also reduce joint pain
lifestyle changes such as resting the
affected joint
and losing weight if necessary may help
slow down the progression of
osteoarthritis other lifestyle changes
include physical therapy exercises
and education to manage osteoarthritis
on your own physical therapy exercises
along with low-impact exercise such as
walking and swimming increases muscle
strength and keeps joints limber braces
can help with joint support and
alignment to reduce joint pain another
treatment option is the injection of
hyaluronic acid into the joint
hyaluronic acid is a naturally occurring
substance in the joint synovial fluid it
helps lubricate the joint and allows the
bones to slide over each other more
easily
for severe osteoarthritis a doctor may
recommend a surgical procedure such as
joint resurfacing to remove loose bone
or cartilage and bone spurs or an
osteotomy or bone removal may be
recommended to realign deformed joints
in some cases the arthritic joint may
need to be replaced with an artificial
joint
for more information talk to a
healthcare provider